liz sam
today i mean we were standing out here
and we saw the free brittany crowd erupt
into cheers given the fact that you two
have devoted so much time and energy and
two documentaries to this how do you
feel about today's outcome
um i mean you know brittany has been
asking for this for a long time we know
from the confidential court documents
that we um obtained that at least as
early as 2014 she's been talking about
uh removing her father trying to
communicate it to the court so i think
you know it feels like it's been a
really long time that she's been
communicating this so it was definitely
very moving to be in the crowd when
everyone realized that it happened liz
you were in the courtroom we were
getting some bits and pieces that um
jamie's attorneys were questioning the
new york times uh content and that
matthew rosengart was adamantly saying
he was looking into these allegations
what was your reaction when you were
hearing some of that discussion of the
work
i was surprised because jamie's lawyer
seemed to refer to it as just a
television show seemingly dismissing the
allegations but we made repeated efforts
to request for comment for them and they
never denied the allegations that they
wiretapped brittany's bedroom and that
they read her texts with her lawyer
can you tell me about that information
has become so key matthew rosengart was
just talking about it again here now
what was it like for you to i don't know
how you made contact but to first hear
from that former member of the company
that did britney security and as you're
hearing these allegations
what did you know that you had there
yeah i mean i think we were both totally
shocked um he reached out to us and the
first time we talked to him we talked
for 10 hours actually because there was
just so much to talk about
and i think
you know you had heard rumors about
things for a long time but to actually
see someone come forward with evidence
and and of things that seem even more
extreme than than we would have imagined
or the public would have imagined it was
it was a really uh
surprising conversation so one thing
that's revealed is that this employee
kept a file he was told to delete 180
hours of audio recordings where is that
content now and what's happened to it so
we've reviewed a copy of the audio
recording in order to authenticate that
it was real and it was really disturbing
to listen to you know britney is being
recorded in her bedroom and her
interactions and conversations with her
kids her boyfriend and others were
secretly recorded
so matthew just told me he's uh he's
going to keep looking into this he's
going to pursue and look at everything
jamie did over this decade including
that are you all working with him at all
sharing your findings with him
um i mean we're we're the new york times
we're journalists so uh we're not
working with lawyers um
i mean could you potentially be
subpoenaed would you have to hand
anything
i don't know we'll see we haven't been
contacted yet by law enforcement
so from here
where do you to go i mean i think the
fans and ever the public were so
incredibly captivated to see a second
piece from you will there be more from
here
you know we're still continuing to
report the start of story is far from
over so we're still looking for people
with uh you know first-hand experience
and and evidence of anything they want
to come forward and tell us about
and we'll see what happens we filmed
here today just in case so
yeah i think there's definitely a lot
more to report over the last 13 years a
lot happened a lot of money was made a
lot of people were involved and we want
to investigate everything
being in the courtroom today if you can
just kind of you know give me your your
version your take on what the experience
was like the back and forth between
those lawyers so there was a really long
back and forth between britney's lawyer
matthew rosengart and jamie's lawyer
vivian thurine and it was really hard as
a bystander to see which way the judge
was going to rule there were various
times where it seemed like vivian was
winning other times it seems like
matthew was winning and then ultimately
when the judge said i'm going to remove
jamie it was uh pretty shocking
we heard out here was there an actual
gasp in the courtroom i didn't hear a
gasp in the courtroom but i would have
loved to hear the reaction out here
yeah i have i i'll send you the video it
was cheers it was we did it it was he's
gone it was
um
so yeah i mean again the movement you
know
the movement really did this and
when you all look at the totality of
this
what do you think you will remember the
most about today
um i mean i think for me it will be
the the people that i saw shaking when
they heard the news and i was lucky
enough to kind of be in the center of
everyone screaming around me so probably
that because a lot of these fans they
had this feeling something was wrong for
so long but they didn't know
and they were kind of going on this gut
instinct people were calling them
conspiracy theorists calling them crazy
i think somebody said to me like who's
crazy now or something but and i think
um they really stuck to their instincts
and it so it's a big deal
yeah i think i'd also say just seeing
the faces of people who've been at these
rallies for years now and who had you
know when they were just tiny tiny
crowds and now seeing all the energy and
all the people that's just very
memorable
do you all have more uh that you
people came to you with more you might
have more that you couldn't share
legally or that you might share in the
future that's two separate questions
i think yeah we have a lot of
information that we're still reporting
out and trying to corroborate and we
hope to publish